turn your boards this is GM Daniel
nitzki and we are watching Magnus
Carlson taking on Ali Raza fua at the
2023 Champions chess tour finals this is
an Armageddon game Ali Raza perua will
start with the black pieces and he'll
have 9 minutes on his clock but if the
game ends in a draw then the match Goes
To Oi resm the game is underway and a
queen gam of decline a slav defense
chosen by Ali Resa fua one of the most
solid ways of meeting the queen Gambit
and Magnus Carlson with an early
surprise pushing up that pawn to F3 as
he cradles his head in his hands that is
not a common move Knight F3 and queen B3
are far more standard and you can see
that reflected in the fact that alza is
taking his time to choose a way to
respond to this move now what is the
point of F3 well clearly Magnus Carlson
is preparing some sort of expansion
either on the king side with G2 G4 or
potentially in the center with E4 but
that's not a move that Magnus can make
just yet alza responds with kind of a
semi- waiting move H6 creating a Escape
Square for his Bishop on H7 Magnus
Carlson uh he doesn't care about the
rules he cares about his opening
preparation G4 is on the board chasing
away ala oa's Bishop all the way back to
H7 Bishop to D3 is his choice offering
an exchange of light squared Bishops and
potentially Ali resa is going to spend a
lot of time moving that light squared
Bishop which is now traded Bishop takes
D3 ala accepts the trade he really had
no choice Bishop G8 would have been way
too passive and now the pace of play is
accelerating slightly E6 by fua all
standard slav moves Magnus Carlson
develops his Knight to E2 and now
reduces the central tension by
exchanging on D5 and Ali Reza captures
towards the center keeping the relative
symmetry of the Central Pawn set up
Bishop D2 by Carlson completing his
minor piece development and A6 the
immediate response by Ali RZA covering
the B5 Square making sure that in the
future magnus's Knight or maybe his
Queen doesn't jump to that B5 Square
which could be very unpleasant if a
white Rook lands on C1 and there's that
H4 move it came a little bit later than
we anticipated and alyzza responds by
striking away at the queen side both
sides expanding on their respective
sides of the board and which way is
Magnus going to Castle he's not going to
castle at all instead he's going to play
King F2 what an unconventional opening
on display here by Magnus but I actually
like the way that this looks for white
he's got these pawns on G4 and H4 and
when the time is right he can keep
striking away at the king side with G5
but if you play that move prematurely
then White's kingside may start to
crumble and the King on F2 is actually
quite safe it may appear ugly but look
at that pawn on F3 and look at how it
restricts the Knight on F6 as oi Resa
completes his kingside development and
there we go G5 by Magnus Carlson the
tension has already reached a peak and
we're barely out of the opening the
Knight slides over to H5 that is of
course the square uh that Carlson's Pawn
vacated when it reached G5 and there's
E4 the move that was prepared by F3 so
many moves ago olus is hesitating he
exchanges in the center but after F
takes E4 that will give Magnus Carlson a
full complement of Pawns in the center
but look at Carlson taking his time a
lot of people would automatically
recapture on e4 with a pawn and maybe
that will be Magnus Carlson's choice but
he is definitely weighing the
alternative Knight takes C4 is a move
that requires consideration because it
hits the bishop on D6 and it centralizes
the Knight and even the unconventional
Queen takes E4 probably deserves
attention and there it is Knight takes
E4 Magnus Carlson continues to fight for
the initiative hitting ala Fu's Bishop
where is that Bishop going to move to it
moves back to E7 adding some pressure on
the G5 pawn and the bigger question for
black is in the long run where is Ali
Reza going to tuck his King away because
he can stay in the center for the time
being but eventually the center is going
to become less of a safe place and a
case in point there as Carlson strikes
away first at the king side now at the
queen side the B5 Pawn sticks out like a
sore thumb and Carlson attacks it by
pushing his Corner Pawn up to A4 he
seems very satisfied with the way that
the game is unfolding alza is under a
lot of fire on all three sides of the
board Magnus has that pawn on A4 he's
got stuff going on the king side and his
Knight on e4 is controlling the center
and there it is Knight Knight to E5 alza
takes the plunge and gets his Knight and
trenches it on the Outpost on C magnus's
response is immediate Bishop up to B4
offering an exchange of dark Squad
Bishops maybe ala can take on B4 and
follow up with Queen to E7 but no he
fights fire with fire F7 F5 much to the
surprise and maybe the Chagrin of Magnus
Carlson as ala pushes his Pawn up and
says no I am not taking things sitting
down of course he is physically sitting
down but that pawn in F5 is anything but
sitting down it hits Magnus Carlson's
Knight on e4 and if Carlson takes on pan
if he plays G takes F6 oy Resa will
finally be able to free his knight from
its prison on H5 and he takes on E7 he
does not take on pant he exchanges the
Bishops and will likely put his own
Knight on the equivalent outpost on C5 a
very elegant construction there with
black sight on C4 and its counterpart on
C5 attacking pressuring that E6 Pawn Oz
is in trouble here he castles kingside
sees nothing better Magnus says thank
you very much exchanges Pawn exchanges
Rooks and picks up the loot on B5
Carlson looks away as if to say look
everybody I have actually won a pawn
that is the result of the middle game
and Carlson now has a clean healthy
extra Pawn it's also a pass pawn and he
says I'm not done there I'm not going to
stop at one Pawn he's also going after
oi rez's Pawn on E6 that is why Carlson
calmly carefully slides his Rook over to
G1 X rang Black's King but most
importantly defending the pawn on G5 and
if alza still plays H takes G5 Carlson
will likely capture with his rook and
Chase the Knight out of H5 and look at
the Knight on E2 that Knight is a
rearing to go it is rearing to jump into
F4 and add a third attacker to that
backward Pawn on E6 and so King H7 by
alza getting away from the pin and
Carlson Maneuvers his Knight back to D3
hither and thither that Knight goes
chiseling his way into the weaknesses
and Black's position that E5 Square
looks like an even juicier Outpost for
white KN as fua tries to solidify his
kingside with the move G6 and the game
is far from over Carlson is up a pawn he
is clearly better in this position but
his Pawn structure overall is still very
flimsy his King on F2 is still not that
safe Black's Queen can try to eventually
find inroads let's say that Queen from
E7 jumps to C7 it'll have direct access
to that juicy Square on H2 Carlson
taking a think and Knight E to F4 that
was the move that he was preparing by
dropping the other Knight back to to D3
it actually was not Knight E5 it was
Knight to F4 offering an exchange of
knights baruja taking a long thing here
what does he do does he try to keep the
knights on the board with Knight H5 to
G7 well that doesn't look appealing at
all because then Carlson will definitely
occupy the other outpost on E5 with his
other Knight and a little slam of the
table by fua who's feeling increasingly
frustrated he doesn't know what to do I
think he has to exchange Knights and he
does and maybe play a move like H5 try
to close up that King side and Fus
on defending his other weakness on E6
but then then Carlson's Rook can slide
from G1 over to E1 and very likely the
E6 Pawn will fall as well and if hza
goes down two Pawns in this position
then well his position will likely be
indefensible and so instead he trades on
G5 and tries to keep White's Rook tied
down to the G file H takes G5 is on the
board the safer move and it is still
followed by Knight F7 alza going after
Carlson's only weakness the G5 Pawn is
now Under Fire how is mag going to
defend it well he can drop his knight
from F4 back to H3 but that's an
incredibly passive move and then alza
could work on opening up the center and
eradicating his weakness with E5 and a
little bit of consternation there as
Magnus Carlson changes his sitting
position pondering this incredibly
complex scenario I really like the way
that o Resa has handled the defensive
task Carlson methodically slides his
Queen from B3 to E3 and Knight takes G5
oza doesn't buy it he says give me that
pawn what has Magnus cooked up here is
it Knight takes G6 is there a beautiful
tactic looming in the air Knight takes
G6 King takes G6 and then white could
recover the Knight with F4 but with only
three pawns on the board that might not
be enough to secure Victory also Knight
takes G6 black could throw in an
intermediate move a check on H3 could be
considered by oi Resa so a lot to
calculate here oi Resa will block with
Queen F6 and Carlson kind of throws his
hands in the air how could there be
nothing here as Carlson fidgeting and
looking from from side to side he's
trying to find a win here he's trying to
find a Knockout but this is why he's
Magnus Carlson he's always able to find
ways to tighten the screws even when it
seems like he's all out of resources
Carlson clearly overlooked something and
queen E5 finally a decision made by the
highest rated player in history he
centralizes his Queen and oy Reza calmly
drops his Knight back to F7 and says get
out of there get off me and Rook H1
check King G8 that the square on h8 is
protected by black snight that night is
an absolute hero look at that Knight on
F7 it attacks the queen and it defends
the square on h8 but a little bit of
hesitation by fua King to gate very very
close to Checkmate but there is no
Checkmate and Carlson he seems more
dejected than ever because he's going to
have to likely drop his Queen all the
way back either to E3 or to E1 he can
also capture on G6 does Carlson have a
different option in mind yes he does
Queen to B5 and with low time fua has to
keep himself on his toes the G6 Pawn is
now hanging that is why he's about to
bring his King up there it is King to G7
another careful defensive move by fua
Carlson has to continue manufacturing
threats against Black's King which is
doing such a good job of protecting G6
Queen C6 sliding the queen in fuja with
a minute on his clock G5 what a bold
decision giving white the H5 Square the
Knight can jump in with check but after
King G6 Black's King is surrounded by a
cocoon a defensive Cocoon of Pawns and
pieces and Carlson continues to shake
his head but he's got to keep trying the
Knight slides back to D3 Ali Resa now
should be able to hold this with best
play but we know that things can turn
around in time pressure as Carlson drops
his Queen back to C3 and x-rays black
king queen F6 by fua and Knight C5 what
a tricky move what a tricky move Rook
takes D4 would have run into to Knight
takes E6 check so fuja gets his King out
of the Queen's line of fire the tension
reaching a peak Magnus still plenty of
time on his clock but can he find a way
to keep causing problems to Ala Rook to
D1 not the move that Carlson wanted to
play now his King is all alone and E5
the move that we mentioned much earlier
ala trying to solve his problems
tactically but did he blunder he did a
sigh of exasperation OA simply forgot
that white could take the pawn and
attack the queen Now The Rook on D1 is
Untouchable and most importantly if oi
Resa recaptures on E5 with his Knight
then his Queen is overloaded he chose
the wrong moment to play E5 and he's got
to move his Queen back and now he's down
a pawn and now Magnus with once again
serious winning chances as he swaps
Rooks Rook takes d8 ala could give a
check on H2 and he does he's starting to
hunt for White's King Carlson a little
bit of hesitation King to E3 the king
seeking its Fortunes in the center and O
Resa recaptures on d8 now Magnus is once
again up a PA but once again the game is
far from Over the King on E3 is going to
be subject to a barrage of checks by
that bloodthirsty black queen how does
Carlson arrange his Queen and his King
in order to deal with those checks a lot
of hesitation Magnus King to D4 the
Monarch taking matters into its own
hands and it's trying to infiltrate
black side of the territory G4 by Ala he
creates a pass Pawn of his own a
diagonal check on F2 where is Magnus
going to go forward it goes to D5 this
is Sparta says Magnus Carlson but Ali
Resa he's got a pass Pawn of his own and
it's only a couple of steps from
promotion will Magnus now push his E
Pawn forward to E6 yes he does he's
faster that pawn two steps away from
promotion a check on F5 by oi Reza can
the king evade the queen and the knight
in close quarter combat I think King D6
looks really really good here King D6
and the Knight on d8 is completely
restricted by The Pawn on E6 and by the
Knight on C5 which prevents a check on
B7 Black's Queen can continue to check
the king and can give a check on F4 but
that King can continue going forward and
it does King D6 and I think Magnus is
getting out of the checks and oi Resa
with Queen to F3 offering an exchange of
Queens but that might be a losing move
Magnus could trade Queens
and he could stop the pawn with Knight
to D3 or Knight to E4 Carlson with
plenty of time to calculate the
variations Queen F3 a desperation move
by oi Resa and how is Carlson going to
navigate the complications he simply
trades the queens and will he push his
Pawn up to E7 ala will respond with F2
but then White's Queen with queen with
check E8 Queen is a check and instead
Carlson with a measured methodical move
Knight to D3 simply preventing the pawn
from moving forward and now E7 and Ali
Resa will be forced to give up his
Knight in order to prevent promotion
it's all over F2 Ali Resa dropped his
clock but the position is losing anyway
what an effort by Magnus Carlson as he
pulls off the game absolutely
unbelievable fuja came oh so close but
his time pressure and Magnus Carlson's
ability to put pressure in any position
ultimately prevailed folks thank you so
much for watching this Carlson fuja
Armageddon game from the 2023 CCT finals
I'll see you in a subsequent
video